ازمه العملات المشفره وخصوصا شركه اف تي
اكس هزت السوق الصاعده بل وجهت لها ضربه
قسمه على الاقل حاليا فبعد اعتقال مؤسس
الشركه سان باكمان فريد في جزر البهاما
قبل ايام اعلن المدعي الامريكي داميان
ويليامز ان المؤسس المشارك لافت اكس جاري
وانغ والمدير التنفيذي السابقه لشركه
الميدا للابحاث كارولاين اليسون اعترف
بالذنب في تهاما فيدراليه وجهت لهما وذلك
بعد ما اقر بنك في ازمه الشركه التي هزت
السوق المشفره وحولت الرجل بين ليله
وضحاها من ملياردير الى الرجل لا يملك
شيئا تبخرت ثروه مؤسس البالغه 25 مليار
دولار خلال اسبوع وبقى المستثمرون حائرون
من اين وكيف
سيستعدون اموالهم ان استطاعه
[موسيقى]
وكانت لجنه الاوراق الماليه
ضد وانغو والسن زعيمه انهما متورتان في
مخطط متعدد السنوات للاحتيال على مستثمر
هيئه الاوراق الماليه
من شركه
وفيما لم يقدم الامريكي تفاصيل محدده بشان
التهم الموجهه الى اليسون الى ان لجنه
الاوراق الماليه تدعي انهما حرض بنك على
الاحتيالي على العملاء المدعي العام اكد
ان باتمان فرايد الذي تم توجيه التهم اليه
لائحه من التهام فعليا بالاحتيال وغسل
الاموال وانتهاكات تمويل الحملات محتاجه
حاليا لدى مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
بينما افادت اللجنه بان 1 انشا بابا خلفيا
للبرامج في منصه اف تي اكس ما سمح لشركه
الميدا بتحويل اموال العملاء الى صفقاتها
الخاصه وبذلك اصبحت اليسن واونج ثاني
وثالث شخصين يتم اتهامهما فيما يتعلق
بانهيار افت اكس بمليارات الدولار
[موسيقى]